>> Jason: WELCOME BACK TO
THIS "HANNITY" SPECIAL.
"JUSTICE IN AMERICA."
THE COLLUSION OBSESSED HOUSE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE VOTED THIS
WEEK TO HOLD A.G. BILL BARB IN
CONTEMPT FOR DECLINING -- BILL
BARR IN CONTEMPT FOR DECLINING
TO HAND OVER THE COMPLETELY
UNREDACTED MUELLER REPORT.
DESPITE THE FACT THEY HAVE ALL
BUT TWO LINES OF THE MUELLER
REPORT BUT THEY ARE REDACTED
IN ACCORDANCE TO THE FEDERAL
LAW.
NOT A SINGLE DEMOCRAT, NOT
ONE, BOTHERED TO READ IT.
TALK ABOUT THE HYPOCRISY.
LET'S NOT FORGET HOW DEMOCRATS
REACTED WHEN OBAMA ATTORNEY
GENERAL HOLDER WAS HELD IN
CONTEMPT OVER HIS HANDLING OF
THE FAST AND FURIOUS SCANDAL.
WATCH THIS.
>> TO BRING ATTEMPT OF
CONGRESS, AGAINST THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL, THEY ARE
CONTEMPTIBLE.
THE RUSH THEY ARE PUTTING ON
IT IS INEXFLICKABLE. EX -- INEXP
IT IS INEXFLICKABLE. EX -- INEXI
IT IS INEXFLICKABLE. EX -- INEXA
IT IS INEXFLICKABLE. EX -- INEXL
IT IS INEXFLICKABLE. EX -- INEX.
WHAT ARE THEY DOING?
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT JOBS
AND THEY ARE GOING ON WITCH
HUNTS.
>> THEY ARE ATTEMPTING TO
BRING CONTEMPT RESOLUTION TO
THE FLOOR AGAINST THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
TO SAY THIS IS A USE OF
CONGRESS AND POWER AND TIME IS
AN UNDERSTATEMENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THE FACTS.
THIS IS ABOUT POLITICS.
>> THEY HAVE NOT FOUND ANY
EVIDENCE THAT THIS ATTORNEY
GENERAL WAS HIDING ANYTHING.
THAT HE HAD LIED TO ANYBODY.
THEY STILL DO NOT HAVE ANY
FACTS TO SUPPORT THIS
ILLEGITIMATE INVESTIGATION.
>> TO THE REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES, SHAME ON YOU.
>> SHAME ON YOU.
SHAME ON YOU.
>> Jason: WOW!
JOINING US NOW WITH REACTION,
AMERICAN CONSERVATIVE UNION
CHAIRMAN MATT SLAP, THE
JUDICIAL WATCH TIM FINTON AND
TAMMY BRUCE JOINING US IN
STUDIO IN NEW YORK.
I WANT TO THANK ALL THREE OF
YOU TO BE HERE.
THE FAST AND FURIOUS THING IS
CLOSE TO MY HEART.
I WAS THERE IN CONGRESS WHEN
IT FIRST STARTED, MATT.
I GOT TO TELL YOU, THEY WERE
KNOWINGLY AND WILLINGLY THE
GOVERNMENT GAVE 2,000 WEAPONS
TO THE DRUG CARTEL.
WE HAVE A DRUG BORDER PATROL
AGENT AND YET THESE SAME
PEOPLE -- COMPARE AND CONTRAST
THE REACTION TO THAT VERSUS
WHAT IS GOING ON TODAY.
>> PEOPLE GET KILLED IN THESE
TERRIBLE CIRCUMSTANCES.
LIKE FAST AND FURIOUS.
THE A. G. WAS COMPELLED TO
TURN OVER RECORDS WHICH HE
STONE WALLED CONGRESS OVER.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN OVER 200
YEARS THE HOUSE HAS MOVED TO
CONDEMN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FOR NOT WILLING TO BE
SCRUTINIZED BY A STAFFER ON
THE COMMITTEE, WHICH YOU KNOW
IS AN ABSURD CRITERIA WE
HAVEN'T DONE FOR TWO CENTURIES
WITHOUT SOME NEGOTIATION.
HE IS WILLING TO TESTIFY.
ON THE MUELLER REPORT, HE
DOESN'T HAVE TO TURN IT OVER
TO CONGRESS.
IT'S AT HIS DISCRETION.
HE CHOSE TO TURN IT OVER TO
MAKE IT PUBLIC.
HE CHOSE TO MAKE AN ALMOST
UNREDACTED COPY AVAILABLE TO
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE DEMS AND
THE REPUBLICANS IN CONGRESS.
AND THE DEMOCRATS DON'T EVEN
WANT TO READ IT.
YOU KNOW WHY?
THEY KNOW THERE IS NO
COLLUSION OR OBSTRUCTION IN
THIS REPORT.
IT'S JUST POLITICS.
THEY WANT TO CONTINUE TO PLAY
POLITICS.
>> THIS IS THE THING.
TAMMY, IT'S THERE IN BLACK AND
WHITE.
IT'S RIGHT THERE IN FRONT OF
THEM.
ALL OF THE REPORT EXCEPT WHAT
IS REQUIRED BY LAW.
I LIKEN IT TO THE SUPREME
COURT.
WHEN THEY COME OUT WITH A
RULING, THEY DON'T HOLD A
PRESS CONFERENCE AND ANSWER
QUESTIONS.
IT'S JUST THERE TO REVIEW.
NOW IN THE WORLD DO THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE ANY CREDIBILITY
ON THIS ISSUE?
>> THEY DON'T.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVELY ATTACKING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL FOR
FOLLOWING THE LAW.
>> Jason: RIGHT.
>> I THINK IT'S PERFECT FOR
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEY HATE THAT.
THEY HATE THAT LAW.
THIS IS REALLY WHEN YOU GEN UP
YOUR BASE FOR SOMETHING AS
RIDICULOUS AND HYPER OBSURED ABS
RIDICULOUS AND HYPER OBSURED ABR
RIDICULOUS AND HYPER OBSURED ABD
LIKE SAYING THAT THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES IS A
RUSSIAN STOOGE OR A RUSE SPY,
HOW CAN YOU TOP THAT?
YOU HAVE TO TOP IT.
I GUESS NOW THE LINE IS THAT
THERE IS A CONSTITUTIONAL
CRISIS.
BUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THEY
ARE SMART.
THIS IS ALSO AN INDICATION OF
THE CONTEMPT WITH WHICH THE
DEMOCRATS AND CERTAINLY NADLER
IN PARTICULAR, HOLD THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN.
THAT YOU WOULDN'T BE SAYING
THIS IF YOU HAD ANY RESPECT
FOR HOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE VIEWING THIS AND WHAT IS
AT STAKE.
AND HOW IT WOULD BE VIEWED.
YOU THINK EVERYBODY IS A DUMB
RUBE AND THEY WON'T FIGURE IT
OUT.
I THINK ACTUALLY YOU WOULD
KNOW, WALK ACROSS A COUPLE OF
HALLWAYS TO SEE THIS.
THEY DON'T NEED TO JUMP
THROUGH HOOPS TO SEE IT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE WANT THEM
TO DO A JOB.
I DON'T THINK THEY HAD THIS IN
MIND WHEN THEY VOTED HIM TO
POWER IN THE MIDTERM.
>> Jason: LOOK, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL IS DOING AN ABSOLUTE
FANTASTIC JOB.
NO NONSENSE.
BEEN THERE AND DONE THAT.
HE IS DOING WHAT HE IS
SUPPOSED TO DO.
TOM, JUDICIAL WATCH, I MEAN
THEY HAVE LED THE CHARGE TO
TRY TO EXPOSE WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS DOING.
COMPARE AND CONTRAST FOR US
YOUR EXPERIENCE WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
IT'S NOT AS IF THEY WERE OPEN,
TRANSPARENT AND COMPLYING WITH
THE LAW ALONG THE WAY, WERE
THEY?
>> NO.
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ESPECIALLY IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION LED BY ERIC
HOLDER FOR A PERIOD OF TIME
WAS A BLACK HOLE IN
TRANSPARENCY.
BUT AS YOU KNOW, IT CONTINUED
UNDER JEFF SESSIONS AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT STILL.
I RECOGNIZE YOU HAVE THE
FIGHTS BETWEEN THE LEGISLATIVE
BRANCH AND THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH ABOUT DOCUMENTS.
BUT THIS IS A TRIFLE OF A
FIGHT.
THIS MATERIAL WAS ESSENTIALLY
MADE AVAILABLE WITHIN THE LAST
FEW WEEKS.
AND THEY IMMEDIATELY RUSH THE
CONTEMPT RESOLUTION AGAINST
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL.
TO ME THIS IS AN ABUSE OF
POWER AND IT FITS IN PERFECTLY
WITH WHAT HAPPENED IN 2016
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS ABUSED THE
POWER.
THEY WERE TARGETING PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY CONTINUED TO THE MUELLER
OPERATION.
THAT SMEAR OF A REPORT.
THEY ARE PICKED UP BY THE
DEMOCRATS WHO WON'T WANT TO
TALK ABOUT THE CRIMINAL
CONSPIRACY THE PARTY IS
INVOLVED IN, IN 2016 AND 2017
TO TARGET PRESIDENT TRUMP WITH
ILLEGAL SPYING.
THEY WOULD RATHER TALK ABOUT
THE PRETEND FIGHT WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR, WHO
THEY ARE SMEARING.
AND THE AWESOME POWER THEY
HAVE TO HOLD SOMEONE IN
CONTEMPT, IT'S PRETTY DARN
SERIOUS WHEN THEY START
INVOKING IT LIGHTLY.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVELY SAYING
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE
UNITED STATES NEED TO BE PUT
IN JAIL OVER A FEW LINES OF
TEXT THAT WE ARE FIGHTING
ABOUT.
THEY WANT TO JAIL POLITICAL
OPPONENTS THE RULE OF LAW AND
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> Jason: ARE THEY JUST
TRYING TO DISTRACT FROM THE
FACT WE HAVE A PENDING
INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT AND
THAT THE ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
LOOKING INTO SPYING AND OTHER
TYPE OF THINGS THAT THE
DEMOCRATS MAY HAVE BEEN DOING
PREVIOUSLY?
>> WE ARE BACK IN THE ELECTION
SEASON.
THINK ABOUT IT, JASON.
THEY WAITED SO LONG THAT NOW
IT'S ABOUT THEIR WRONGDOING.
THAT IS WHAT WE TALK ABOUT
WITH THE I.G. REPORT COMES
BACK TO.
WHAT DID JOE BIDEN KNOW?
THAT IS WHAT REPUBLICANS NEED
TO START ASKING.
>> Jason: THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION AND WE ONLY HAVE 30
SECONDS LEFT.
TAMMY AND TOM, WHERE DO YOU
THINK THE CONTEMPT GOES NEXT?
>> I THINK OBVIOUSLY THEY HAVE
THE VOTES TO DO IT.
WE'LL SEE IF THE DEMOCRATS
HAVE COURAGE TO ADMIT THIS IS
RIDICULOUS.
MAYBE NOT EVERY DEMOCRAT WILL
GO FOR IT.